[Musik]
und jetzt das heute schon mal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka
guten Abend der amerikanische
Verteidigungsminister Austin hatte das
Treffen in Ramstein mit einem
eindringlichen Appell begonnen das
ukrainische Volk sieht uns zu der Kreml
sieht uns zu die Geschichte sieht uns zu
nun liegt es in der Natur der Sache dass
man ein braunview mit der Geschichte
meist erst im Nachhinein abschließend
beurteilen kann das Urteil der
zusehenden Ukrainer kennt man jetzt
schon mit Blick auf die Kampfpanzer
bittere Enttäuschung und das Urteil des
kremme kann man vermuten na gut wenn der
Feind sich uneins ist denn das ist das
ja was Verteidigungsminister Pistorius
nach der Sitzung verkünden musste keine
Einigung beim Thema Kampfpanzer dabei
hatte Pistorius sich gestern hier im
heute journal noch so zuversichtlich
gezeigt Andreas berichtet
am Ende dieser verrückten Woche steht
Boris Pistorius auf einem Parkplatz auf
dem
US-Luftwaffenstützpunkt Ramstein und
muss die Position des Kanzlers vertreten
die Ukraine vertrösten ein Dutzend
Verbündeter Staaten verärgern und
trotzdem irgendwie das Ansehen
Deutschlands retten und sein Mantel ist
auch weg ein paar Meter weiter klettern
die Vertreter von mehr als 50 Staaten in
den Rammstein officers Club die Ukraine
die von Deutschland die Lieferung von
Leopard 2 Panzern wollen die Polen die
von Deutschland die Genehmigung wollen
Leopard 2 Panzer zu liefern die
Amerikaner die wollen das Deutschland
Leopard 2 Panzer liefert und andern die
Genehmigung zum Liefern erteilt es tagt
die Ukraine Kontaktgruppe und es ist
eilig time Zeit bleibt eine russische
Waffe wir müssen schneller werden Zeit
muss unsere gemeinsame Waffe werden
dabei schneller werden bei Zeit dürften
die Blicke auf Germany fallen so offen
wie nie haben Polen Großbritannien
Litauen haben einige der engsten
Verbündeten das Land das Boris Pistorius
seit gestern vertritt aufgefordert nicht
länger zu zögern allen voran die USA in
seltener Offenheit teilt ein Sprecher
des
us-verteidigungsministers gestern mit
Austin werde in Ramstein die deutschen
bedrängen aber die deutschen drängen
zurück aus Davos wird ein Treffen von
Bundeskanzler Scholz mit 12
us-kongressabgeordneten bekannt einer
von ihnen der Demokrat Set Moden
Verräter nach verblüfft wie weit
auseinander man lag Scholz war erzählt
Motten ziemlich direkt Deutschland werde
keinen Leopard 2 liefern wenn nicht auch
die Verbündeten Kampfpanzer liefern das
Großbritannien mit seinem Challenger 2
den Anfang macht reicht Scholz nicht
Berlin will auch Washington liefern
sehen am liebsten den schweren aber auch
schwer zu handhabenden Abrams nicht als
Bedingung aber als ganz starken Wunsch
sie stehen in Jacke da ich nicht mein
Mantel ist irgendwie abhanden gekommen
das Pistorius ohne Mantel aber vor allem
ohne Ergebnis aus den Verhandlungen
kommt ist kein schöner Moment sondern
einer den der neue ein bisschen
schönreden muss es gibt kein
einheitliches Meinungsbild der Eindruck
der gelegentlich entstanden ist es gebe
eine geschlossene Koalition in
Deutschland stehe im Weg dieser Eindruck
ist falsch wer in Ramstein an
Deutschland Seite stand bleibt offen die
USA waren es nicht ja Deutschland tut
genug aber wir können alle mehr tun
am Ende dieser verrückten Woche
beauftragt der neue Minister die
Bundeswehr die Bestände an Leopard 2 zu
überprüfen nur für den Fall und nur um
von einer Entscheidung des Kanzlers
nicht überrascht zu werden wie am Anfang
dieser verrückten Woche
wie im Kanzleramt dieser Tag bewertet
wird ist nicht ganz leicht einzuschätzen
einerseits hat Scholz sich ja
offenkundig durchgesetzt den Druck nicht
nachzugeben weder den Druck aus der
eigenen Koalition und der Opposition
noch dem internationalen Druck nur genau
bei letzterem liegt natürlich auch das
Problem wo steht Deutschland da bzw wie
steht es da auf einer Führungsposition
jedenfalls ganz sicher nicht im
Gegenteil Christian hübscher hat
Reaktionen im In- und Ausland gesammelt
[Musik]
lasst die Leoparden frei rufen Sie Olaf
Scholz zu zu Hunderten sind sie am Abend
vors Kanzleramt gezogen enttäuschte
Ukraine und Ukrainerinnen die gehofft
hatten auf deutsche Kampfpanzer und der
ehemalige Botschafter vermisst mal
wieder deutsche Führungsstärke
die Bundesregierung tut oder halt nicht
tut und deswegen ist es so bitte und
unter deutschen dass man immer wieder
schaut es nicht gemacht und die werden
weiterhin prüfen Deutschland isoliere
sich immer mehr so sieht es auch die
größte Oppositionspartei nach Rammstein
hat mich fassungslos zurückgelassen der
Verteidigungsminister steht mit Lehrerin
Händen da ich weiß nicht was jetzt noch
geprüft werden soll ganz Europa ehrlich
gesagt die ganze Welt wartet auf meine
deutsche Entscheidung und Bundeskanzler
Scholz blockiert das nach wie vor dass
der neue Verteidigungsminister nicht
weiß wie Leopard 2 man überhaupt abgeben
könnte sorgt unter Militärexperten für
Kopfschütteln also wissen Sie wenn Sie
sich als Verteidigungsminister
hinstellen und sagen sie geben jetzt
einen sogenannten Prüfauftrag um erstmal
durchzuzählen wie viel Waffensysteme
haben sie überhaupt und in welchem
einsatzfähigen Zustand sind die das ist
ja eine völlige bankroterklärung so was
müssten sie per sofort wissen das ist
militärisches Grund Handwerk im
US-Fernsehen Rätselraten über die
deutschen warum verweigern Sie diesen
Schritt fragt der cnn-m-moderator den
Sicherheitsexperten
sehr schwer zu erklären was die
Deutschen denken sagte er die deutschen
denken laut Umfragen zu 42%, das ist
richtig wäre der Ukraine den Leopard 2
zu liefern aber es sind auch 46%, die
das falsch wenden Applaus für Scholz
Zurückhaltung kommt von der AFD bislang
ist positiv zu bewerten dass er dem
Druck auch innerhalb der Koalition stand
mit der Kriegstreiberei von FDP und grün
und ich hoffe dass der Bundeskanzler und
auch Herr Pistorius diesen Druck
weiterhin standhält denn hier geht es um
Krieg oder Frieden die frus
trierten innischen Demonstranten vor dem
Kanzleramt aber rufen heute Abend immer
wieder ein deutsches Wort schade
[Applaus]
ja und dann schalten wir zu Marie Agnes
stark Zimmermann der Vorsitzende des
Verteidigungsausschusses im Deutschen
Bundestag guten Abend Frau Zimmermann
guten Abend Frau Slomka also das
Ergebnis dieses Tages ist nun definitiv
auch nicht das was sie wollten auch
nicht das was der grüne
Koalitionspartner gewollt hätte sie
haben heute Mittag gesagt eine nicht
entscheidungsergebnis das wäre
eigentlich die größte Katastrophe
ja das ist in der Tat so ich habe schon
Befürchtungen gehabt das war ja sehr
medial sehr aufgeladen so nach dem Motto
wie an Silvester um Mitternacht knallen
die Raketen das war mir schon klar dass
es nicht kam aber zumindest wäre ein
Signal richtig gewesen in Partnern schon
mal grünes Licht zu geben das muss ja
nicht jeder sondern die die Leopard 2
haben und bereits sind in die Ukraine zu
verlegen das wäre der erste Schritt
gewesen und das nicht mal das gekommen
ist ist schon nicht nur traurig ist ist
historisch da muss der hat er
amerikanische Verteidigungsminister
Recht die Geschichte schaut auf uns und
Deutschland hat leider gerade versagt
und wird der Kanzler das ja also
hoffentlich nicht nur aus purer Sturheit
so entschieden haben sondern er wird ja
auch seine Motive haben über die dann
auch viel gerätselt wird wie man sieht
auch international gerätet wird wie
erklären Sie sich das
das ist genau der Punkt dass nämlich die
Kommunikation einfach miserabel ist wir
haben auf der einen Seite trut
Deutschland sehr sehr viel am Anfang
langsam dann aber mit hoher
Geschwindigkeit sie wissen was wir alles
geliefert haben bis hin zu iOS Tea diese
erfolgreich im Einsatz ist auf der
anderen Seite ist diese Kommunikation
eine Katastrophe und das kann man auch
keine mehr erklären denn wenn der
Kanzler das nicht will dann muss er das
erklären er muss es uns erklären er muss
es vor allen Dingen den Menschen draußen
erklären und vor allen Dingen
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainern jeden Tag
sterbender unvorstellbar viele Menschen
und die Ukraine das sind heute die
großen Verlierer und das ist einfach nur
beschämend also wenn der Kanzler
überhaupt mal dazu was sagt weil er
direkt gefragt wird dann erklärte dass
er damit dass er eine Eskalation
befürchtet also dass er nicht will dass
ist ein zu einem Krieg kommt zwischen
der Nato und Russland und das ist ja
eine Befürchtung die Offenbarung der
Bevölkerung haben ja eben eine dieser
Umfragen gesehen auch durchaus geteilt
wurde oder wo Deutschland gespalten ist
das scheint sein Motiv zu sein und ist
das so für sie gar nicht nachvollziehbar
naja das ist ein Bundeskanzler natürlich
abwägt das ist selbstverständlich ich
persönlich gehöre aber nicht zu der
Abteilung die morgens immer Umfragen
anschaut und dann Politik macht ich
halte es mit Walter Scheel dass wir
nicht Stimmungen nachgeben sondern kurz
gesagt dass wir Politik machen und diese
populär diese erklären und das erwartet
die Welt auch von der Bundesrepublik wir
sind immer sehr schnell dabei wenn es um
wirtschaftliche Fragen geht wenn es um
moralische Fragen geht sind wir ganz
groß wir haben auch in der Euro-Frage
immer uns wieder auch über Interessen
der Europäer hinweg gesegten Nord Stream
2 das hat Frau Merkel offensichtlich dem
Kanzler schon beigebracht und jetzt eben
dieses es ist ja ein Kompliment an
Deutschland dass man uns trotz unserer
Geschichte heute vertraut dass man
wartet dass wir führen und diesmal
enttäuschen wir dass wir eben dieses
dieses Vertrauen ja nicht mit Händen
greifen und eine Führung übernehmen und
es werden die Leopard 2 Panzer kommen
sie werden kommen weil einfach es
sinnvoll ist und es ist schlimm genug
das ist immer immer wieder Druckbedarf
Lageveränderung um darauf zu reagieren
und der neue Bundesverteidigungsminister
erlebt heute eben und ich glaube ihm
dass er das anders will davon gehe ich
jetzt mal aus erlebt heute das erste Mal
wenn man an der Kette liegt und
eigentlich Dinge anders machen will die
ganze Sache wäre wahrscheinlich nicht so
schwierig wenn es nicht ausgerechnet
Deutschland wäre dass solche offenbar
besonders guten Panzer herstellt nun
Ketten ja auch die Amerikaner sagen
können das haben sie ja schon in der
Vergangenheit getan gut wir bauen dem
Herrn Scholz eine Brücke und liefern
auch was manche Militär experten sagen
ja schon so etwas spöttisch vielleicht
einfach nur ein
Abrams Kanzler Abrams Panzer den hätte
man dann auch in Kiew auf den mal
darstellen können aber die Amerikaner
tun es ja auch nicht
ja aber vor Slomka allein die die
Vorstellung dass die Amerikaner einen
schicken damit wir in die Gänge kommen
das ist ja an Peinlichkeit nicht zu
überbieten wir gehören zu den stärksten
Volkswirtschaften der Welt wir brauchen
doch keinen Symbol das Sterben Menschen
die brauchen dieses Material diese diese
Panzer und insofern wenn die Amerikaner
das nicht liefern ich habe dafür
Verständnis Amerika ist 9000 km weg von
der Ukraine wir haben aber in Europa
fast 3000 Leopard 2 Panzer selbst wenn
man nur ein Bruchteil davon liefern
würde wäre es ein richtiges Zeichen und
sie haben es vorhin in dem Beitrag ja
gesagt es ist ein heute Abend kann sich
Wladimir Putin auf die Schenkel klopfen
der über ihn ist gerade Massenmörder
frei lässt damit sie an der Front
kämpfen das ist so ein bestialischer
Krieg da kann man nur die Ukraine
unterstützen und wenn man es nicht macht
weil man die der Ukraine helfen will
dann weil man ein Land ein Bündnis
verteidigen will und offensichtlich hat
einfach ich bleib mal im Bilde diesen
Knall er ist im Kanzleramt noch
angekommen und ich finde es wirklich
unangenehm ich finde es auch wirklich
zutiefst betrüblich um es mal harmlos
auszudrücken ich kenne die Reaktion der
Menschen auch junger Menschen die
Schütteln mit dem Kopf und ich kann nur
sagen wir werden weiter darum bitten
weiter darauf drängen nicht um Recht zu
haben sondern um die Ukraine zu
unterstützen in ihren Kampf sie sagt
Ihnen wirklich ein brutales Russland sie
sagten gerade putin wird sich die Hände
haben also er wird sich sicherlich
darüber freuen dass hier keine
Geschlossenheit des seiner seiner Gegner
zu sehen war aber andererseits ist
natürlich auch einiges doch auch
beschlossen worden es ging ja heute
nicht nur um die Leoparden die
Amerikaner haben einen riesen Paket
angekündigt viele andere auch die die
beiden die Niederländer bieten alles
mögliche an die denn haben praktisch
ihre gesamte Artillerie zur Verfügung
gestellt und Deutschland liefert weitere
Gefahren also so ein schlechter Tag was
dann für die Ukraine doch auch nicht
ja das ist eben Kommunikation wir
liefern ja eine Menge wie sie das gerade
sagten es werden auch Gebhard über die
üben übrigens viele gelacht haben und
geschmunzelt haben noch vor ein paar
Wochen die enorm wirkungsvoll ist ja das
passiert alles aber jetzt zu erklären
warum wir Panzerhaubitzen schicken warum
wir ja jetzt auch den Marder
Schützenpanzer endlich in die Ukraine
verlegen 40 Stück davon das versteht
keiner warum es just an diesem
Kampfpanzer scheitert und Präsident
selenski hat ja explizit noch mal gesagt
den gegenüber die Sorge haben dass die
Ukraine diesen Panzer zum Angriff nutzen
will dass das ausgeschlossen es geht
darum innerhalb der Ukraine Territorium
zu Verteidigung und da ist der
Schützenpanzer und der Kampfpanzer
ergänzen sich eben und deswegen macht es
so großen Sinn England macht es jetzt
vor mit dem Challenger und wie gesagt es
gibt einige Staaten die das wollen in
Europa es gibt 14 Länder die den Leopard
2 fahren und wenn heute gerufen wird man
soll den Leopard freilassen dann ist das
ein gutes Bild es wäre ein gutes Zeichen
die Erlaubnis zu geben und dann seinen
Teil dazu beizutragen und wer das
narrativ von Wladimir Putin immer vor
sich herträgt wie eine Monstranz weil ja
ich ständig über rote Linien gesprochen
wird das ist die Methode wie uns
Wladimir Putin eben auch vorführen will
und als der Krieg als der Krieg begann
als Wladimir Putin Ukraine angegriffen
hat vor fast einem Jahr hat er ja
geglaubt dass die EU dass wir alle
solche entschuldigen Sie wenn ich das
sage Weicheier sind dass wir überhaupt
nicht in der Lage sind zusammenzuwirken
und wir haben gezeigt Europa steht die
NATO steht das was Wladimir Putin nie
vermutet hätte und wenn man diese
Diskussion sieht oder wenn die Ausrede
benutzt wird es sein sich nicht alle
einig dann zahlt das genau auf dieses
Bild an danke für das Gespräch
danke Frau Slomka und zu dem Thema gibt
es nachher im heute journal Update auch
noch ein Gespräch und zwar mit dem
Sicherheitsexperten Christian Mölling
von der Deutschen Gesellschaft für
auswärtige Politik und mit der Ukraine
geht es jetzt auch bei denen noch mal
weiter als der Bundes
entwicklungsministerin Schulze hat der
Ukraine zusätzliche 52 Millionen Euro
für den Wiederaufbau zugesagt Schulze
hatte sich gestern in der Hafenstadt
Odessa ein Bild von den Zerstörungen und
dem Wiederaufbau gemacht die zusätzliche
millionenhilfe ist für
wärmestubengeneratoren medizinische
Versorgung und Verwaltungen vorgesehen
schwimmende lng-terminals sind Teil der
neuen Gasversorgung Deutschlands zwei
gibt es bereits in ein drittes kam heute
in Brunsbüttel an das Spezialschiff kann
verflüssigtes Erdgas von Tankern
aufnehmen und den Gas umwandeln mit dem
dritten Terminal entstanden Kapazitäten
von 14 Milliarden Kubikmeter Gas pro
Jahr sagte Wirtschaftsminister Habeck
das ist etwa ein Viertel dessen was
früher über die Pipeline Nord Stream
eins nach Deutschland kam
bei erneuten Protesten gegen die
Regierung ist es in Peru zu schweren
Ausschreitungen gekommen in der
Hauptstadt Lima brach ein Großbrand aus
demonstrierende warfen Steine und
Feuerwerkskörper auf Polizisten die
ihrerseits Tränengas in die Menge
feuerten
Regierungsgegner fordern den Rücktritt
der
übergangspräsidentin boulearte die
Auflösung des Kongresses und die
Freilassung des inhaftierten Präsidenten
Castillo
im Tarifstreit bei der Deutschen Post
will die Gewerkschaft Verdi die waren
Streiks fortsetzen am Samstag sollen nun
die Zusteller ihre Arbeit niederlegen
die Gewerkschaft wäre die hatte gestern
und heute ihre Mitglieder in allen
Briefe und Paketzentren zum Ausstand
aufgerufen laut Post sind bundesweiteren
2,3 Millionen Pakete und 13 Millionen
Briefe betroffen die Gewerkschaft
fordert 15% mehr Geld bei einer Laufzeit
von einem Jahr
die agrarmesse Grüne Woche hat begonnen
nach zweijähriger corona-pause wieder
als Live-Ereignis in den Berliner
Messehallen zum Auftakt am Morgen mit
einem Rundgang von bundesagraminister
Özdemir und berlins Regierender
Bürgermeisterin gefeit bis zum 29 Januar
präsentieren sich 1400 Aussteller aus 60
Ländern und die Veranstalter erwarten
rund 300.000 Besucherinnen und Besucher
die Landwirtschaft klagt ja schon seit
langem darüber dass es ihr an
Arbeitskräften fehlt und ist auch immer
schwieriger wird saisonale Erntehelfer
aus dem Ausland zu bekommen das gilt
auch für alle anderen Branchen die mit
harter körperliche Arbeit verbunden sind
inzwischen klagen aber ja auch Bereiche
über Nachwuchsmangel die früher mal zu
den beliebten Arbeitgebern gehörten
Banken Verwaltung Schulen Kitas und
immer wieder ganz besonders betroffen
Handwerk und mittelständische Industrie
so viele Betriebe die Händeringen suchen
die viel mehr Umsatz machen könnten wenn
sie nur das Personal dafür hätten
Sibylle Bastler berichtet
georg tockmakiedes ist verzweifelt in
seiner Firma werden abschleppsysteme für
Autos gebaut seine orderbücher sind voll
mit Aufträgen in Millionenhöhe aus der
ganzen Welt doch er kann nicht liefern
wir Kunden sagen
wir trinken keine Leute und jeder lacht
drüber bloß wo sind sie früher hatte er
30 Mitarbeiter jetzt sind es zehn alles
hat er versucht Anzeigen Arbeitsamt wir
waren in der Berufsschule wir waren in
der in der Hauptschule haben wir sogar
Vorträge gemacht was der Beruf mit sich
bringt bei uns weil es ist etwas
Außergewöhnliches nichts
Nachfrage bei Schülerinnen und Schülern
der Abiturklasse einer Berufsoberschule
alle haben eine Lehre hinter sich
niemand will im erlernten Beruf bleiben
40 Jahre in den Beruf zu arbeiten mit
den körperlichen Belastungen die man
dann immer wieder bekommt
ist jetzt nicht so ansprechend die
Aufstiegschancen sind bis auf den
Meister sehr begrenzt und das hat mir
nicht gereicht mal was Gutes und dann
haben wir gute Chance im Leben das
Handwerker ja da ist man der Knecht in
allen Branchen fehlen Arbeitskräfte
selten waren hierzulande so viele
Menschen im Jobs wie heute das spiegelt
sich auch in den Arbeitsagenturen wieder
historisch hohe Zahlen an offenen
Stellen aber nur wenig Arbeitssuchende
die Folge die Arbeitnehmer können sich
stärker aussuchen in welchem Bereichen
in welchen Berufen sie arbeiten wollen
und welchen Arbeitgeber sie wählen
doch nicht nur der Nachwuchs ist knapp
es droht auch der demografische Wandel
wenn jetzt die Babyboomer in Rente gehen
werden wir im deutschen Arbeitsmarkt bis
2035 um 7 Millionen Personen schrumpfen
7 Millionen das entspricht einem Siebtel
der Arbeitnehmer um diese Lücke zu
schließen müssten ältere Menschen und
Frauen für das Erwerbsleben gewonnen
werden und wir müssen auf Zuwanderung
und eine sehr gute Integration in
Deutschland setzt über das Thema
Fachkräftemangel und mögliche Maßnahmen
wurde heute auch im Bundestag debattiert
wir werden im März an
Einwanderungsgesetz vorlegen dafür zu
sorgen dass helfende Hände und kluge
Köpfe nach Deutschland kommen wenn das
so einfach wäre wären Corona musste
Georg makidis seinen Betrieb monatelang
schließen viele seiner Mitarbeiter aus
Ungarn und Tschechien fuhren damals nach
Hause
und die kommen immer zurück weil ich
sagen ich drücke in meinem Heimatland
mehr unterm Strich was eigentlich in
Deutschland verdiene Steuern Miete
Nebenkosten es bleibe einfach zu wenig
übr
IG Zahlung was der 60-Jährige macht wenn
er nicht bald neue Mitarbeiter findet
im Augenblick müssen soweit dass man
sagen wird und verlagern die Produktion
lassen nur ein kleines Büro zurück keine
guten Nachrichten für den Standort
Deutschland
mit Wirtschaft geht es jetzt auch bei
dir noch mal weiter Heinz und da schauen
wir einmal mehr auf die derzeit hohe
Inflation der Statistische Bundesamt
meldet dass die Erzeugerpreise
gewerbliche Produkte auch im Dezember
wieder gegenüber dem Vormonat leicht
gesunken sind sie nahm jetzt wie ist die
Einschätzung bleibt es bei dieser
Tendenz also sprich zumindest einiges
dafür dass sich die Lage tatsächlich
weiterhin entspannen wird in den USA ist
der Zenit sowohl bei der Inflation als
auch bei den Erzeugerpreisen bereits
überschritten worden ja und wenn bei
einem der wichtigsten Handelspartner die
Preise langsam fallen könnte sich das
auch auf Deutschland auswirken hinzu
kommt dass es hier zu Lande einen
Rückgang der Energiekosten gibt sie
waren ja der Hauptgrund für diese hohen
Erzeugerpreise zwischen November und
Dezember sind die Preise für Mineralöl
und Kraftstoff um jeweils über sieben
Prozent zurückgegangen ja und wenn
Hersteller nun weniger Geld für Energie
aufbringen müssen fallen auch die
Erzeugerpreise
und was heißt das im Ende für die
Verbraucher ja sie werden sich
tatsächlich noch etwas gedulden müssen
seit Oktober geht die Inflation in
Deutschland zwar leicht zurück aber bis
die Hersteller nun ihre niedrigeren
Preise auch tatsächlich an die
Verbraucher weitergeben werden wird es
noch ein Weilchen dauern deutlich
schneller aber dürfte die Europäische
Zentralbank auf diese neuen Zahlen
reagieren im Kampf gegen die Inflation
könnte sie im März vielleicht etwas
Moderator der Moderator die Zinsschraube
nach oben drehen deutlich aufwärts ging
es übrigens auch beim Dax seit
Jahresbeginn hat das Börsenbarometer
inzwischen ein Plus von 8% erzielt
vielen Dank gerne
der US-Musiker David Crosby ist
gestorben im Alter von 81 Jahren der
zehntelang hatte er mit seiner Musik im
Rampenlicht gestanden in den 60er und
70er Jahren prägte er den Sound der
Hippie Ära mit seinen Bands the birds
und Crosby Stills and Nash schaffte er
es gleich zweimal in die Rock n' Roll
Hall of Fame
[Musik]
nach der Bekanntgabe gestern Abend heute
die offizielle Vorstellung von Rudi
Völler als Direktor der
Nationalmannschaft mit Blick auf die
Heim-EM 2024
ein kleinerer Aufgabenbereich als sein
Vorgänger Bierhoff und die Befristung
bis zur Heime im 24 diese beiden Aspekte
haben ihn dann doch ja sagen lassen ich
glaube auch dass ich mit sehr viel Elan
und noch Freude an die Aufgabe
herangehen
dass wir uns auch etwas näher
erfolgsnäher geben seine Kurzanalyse der
verpatzten WM diesen teamspiriert den
Teamgeist der hat da natürlich ein paar
Prozent gefehlt sein Credo Optimismus
hilft aber ich will immer noch davon
überzeugt dass wir eine Mannschaft haben
die in anderthalb Jahren um den Titel
mitspielen kannst meine feste
Überzeugung Völler will nun ganz in der
Rolle des Retters aufgehen
und jetzt zum Schluss noch etwas Schönes
eine Hommage an Pina Bausch die econa
des modernen Tanztheaters die ihre
Kompanie in Wuppertal zu Weltraum
verhalf also 2009 starb war das ein
Schock und riss eine Lücke von der
zunächst niemand wusste ob sie sie
schließen lässt
ersetzen kann man eine solche Ausnahme
KünstlerInnen und Führungsfigur ein
solches kreatives Kraftzentrum natürlich
eh nicht aber zumindest ihr Erbe
erhalten bestenfalls sogar
weiterentwickeln
in diesem Sinne steht in Wuppertal nun
eine besondere Produktion auf dem
Spielplan 2 der legendären Pina Bausch
Choreographien neu interpretiert Kerstin
Edinger hat sich das angesehen
in Strawinskys frühlingsopfer geht es um
einen alten Ritus um die Opferung eines
Menschenlebens Pina Bausch hat dazu 1975
eine berauschende Choreographie
entworfen nun wird sie in Wuppertal von
der ecoldi sable gezeigt von Tänzern und
Tänzerinnen aus 14 afrikanischen Ländern
[Musik]
ich war schon immer von ihr beeindruckt
und habe mir gesagt eines Tages möchte
ich auch so tanzen wie die Tänzerinnen
von Pina es war ein großer Traum und nun
wird er wahr
[Musik]
die pina-baustiftung hat die Truppe die
ihre Wurzeln eigentlich im afrikanischen
Tanz hat beauftragt und zu sehen wie das
Werk neu interpretiert werden kann
Pina baust Sohn Salomon ist Leiter der
Stiftung er kümmert sich seit dem frühen
Tod seiner Mutter vor 13 Jahren nicht
nur um ihr umfangreiches Filmarchiv
sondern auch darum ihre Ideen in die
Zukunft zu führen die Stücke ich glaube
die sind als Kunstwerk schon wichtig sie
auch sozusagen zu erhalten aber da drin
ist so viel Leben und sie dann mit
anderen immer mit wieder auch anderen
Personen in Kontakt zu bringen ist ist
einfach sehr schön für diese Stücke und
für die Leute die es tun und für die
Leute nicht sehen
Pina Baus hat den Tanz weltweit
revolutioniert sie hat das Tor
aufgestoßen zu einer neuen Tanzsprache
mit ihren Stücken wollte sie zum Kern
des Menschseins vordringen
um ihre Philosophie an die jüngere
Generation weiterzugeben leiten ihre
ehemaligen Tänzer heute die Proben auch
bei dem Stück Café Müller ist das so
eines der wenigen Werke in dem Pina
Bausch selbst tanzte
[Musik]
nun wird es immer wieder mit neuen
Tänzerinnen einstudiert
[Musik]
es ist wichtig einfach auch zu sehen wie
die Persona wir wollen keine Leute
klonen und niemand kann Pina Bausch sein
niemand
das alte bewahren ohne in der
Vergangenheit stecken zu bleiben keine
leichte Aufgabe um auch mehr neue Stücke
herauszubringen hat man im letzten Jahr
den französischen Choreografen Boris
hamats ans Haus geholt außerdem soll im
Jahr 2026 für über 60 Millionen Euro ein
großes Pina bauschzentrum gebaut werden
wir wollen es wirklich öffnen und es
soll außerdem einem internationales
Produktionszentrum entstehen bei den
neue neue
künstlerische Produktion entstehen
können
man hat sich viel vorgenommen in
Wuppertal um die Erinnerung an Pina
Bausch lebendig zu halten an ein Werk
das dem Publikum nie nur die Augen
öffnete sondern immer auch die Herzen
das was von uns gleich geht's weiter mit
einer heute-show-spezial mit Lutz van
der Horst und Fabian Küster und um 23
Uhr gibt es dann unser heute schon alle
Update mit Christopher Wehrmann und wir
melden uns morgen schon gegen 21 Uhr in
der Halbzeitpause vom Handball WM Spiel
Niederlande gegen Deutschland bis dahin
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
ich grüße sie Wintersportbegeisterte
wird es freuen in den Mittelgebirgen
liegen jetzt zwischen 5 und 25 cm Schnee
und es bleibt hier in Mitteleuropa kalt
und es kommt sogar noch mal neuer Schnee
dazu und das legt an diesem Tiefe über
Südosteuropa das besonders in der Nacht
zu Sonntag und Sonntag über Tag neue
Schneefälle bringt die breiten sich von
Brandenburg bis nach Baden-Württemberg
aus heute Nacht kann es im Südwesten
noch etwas schneien der Schnee zieht
sich immer mehr nach Süden zurück sie
sollten sich dennoch auf gefährlich
glatte Straßen einstellen es bleibt zum
Teil auch klar und dann wird das eisig
kalt im Sauerland sinken die
Temperaturen bis minus 10 Grad auf den
Ostfriesischen Inseln sind es um 0° und
morgen über Tag ziehen sich die
Schneefälle erstmal Situation zurück
dann kommt das neue Tiefe an und bringt
den nächsten Schnee für viele wird das
aber morgen auch ein freundlicher
Samstag hier zwischen Nordfriesland und
der Mosel werden häufig die Sonne zu
Gesicht bekommen bei Wind aus Nord bis
Nordost so bleibt es kalt im
Dauerschneefall an den Alpen liegen die
Höchsttemperaturen um -4 auf Rügen und
plus 5 Grad und der Sonntag bringt uns
dann mehr Schnee die Schneefälle breiten
sich schon in der Nacht aus tagsüber
wird es dann etwas weniger bevor denn
hier in Sachsen neuer Schnee herankommt
auch dort wird es hin und wieder etwas
Sonnenschein geben besonders im
Nordwesten am Sonntag bei -2-4 Grad und
die neue Woche startet deutlich ruhiger
schönes Wochenende